[Music]
some 130 people mainly woman and
children
were packed on the fishing trawler that
capsized relatives wait anxiously
outside the police station to find more
information on the missing Sabir Begum
was one of the survivors but she lost
her eight-year-old daughter in the
tragedy she was planning to join her
husband who lives in Malaysia when the
boat capsized we all were trying to stay
afloat my child was on my lap but
suddenly slipped and washed by the wave
I cried out loud my child my child but
she was gone by then marriage is another
leader the smugglers commonly used
seventeen-year-old Najma Begum's fiancee
lives in Malaysia her fiance made all
the arrangements with the smuggler she
managed to survive and now regrets ever
attempting the trip at around 3:00 in
the morning the boat carrying us hit a
coral reef
most of us were kept in three separate
hulls in the boat but suddenly people
started shouting
there is water entering please open the
hatch once the boat started sinking we
were let out and eventually rescued
Bangladesh's security services said they
have intercepted at least five hundred
roja refugees from around its shores
since last year but security agency that
made its a major challenge I'm writing
until July we have been able to identify
many of those who are involved in this
human trafficking business so far we
have arrested at least eight of them
after this incident and taking
pre-emptive actions against others we
also have increased patrolling and
surveillance along with the other
security agencies more than seven
hundred and thirty thousand Rohingya
Muslims who fled brutal military
crackdown in Myanmar in 2017 currently
live in a crowded camp in cox's bazar
facing an uncertain future facing
increasing restrictions on the movement
communication blackout and desperate
condition in the camps many Rohingya
refugees are now turning to human
smugglers to ferry them across abroad to
seek a better life willing to take a
dangerous journey through the Bay of
Bengal
Bangladesh's government says it is
working hard to tackle the problem but
it meets it's a huge task
Chandra Chaudhary al Jazeera Cox's Bazar
Bangladesh